[Musique]
je ne suis pas le père noël mais presque
tout ça ce sont des produits tech à
moins de 100 euros alors qu'il en existe
plein ils l'idée aujourd'hui c'est je
pose avant de faire une colle une l'idée
c'est que tout le monde n'a pas
forcément 200 300 400 voire même un peu
plus à dépenser dans des produits tech a
forcément ça coûte très cher et la fois
pour toutes les bourses
et c'est pas forcément possible donc je
me suis dit aujourd'hui je vous présente
et des produits tech à moins de 100
euros alors on n'aura pas la même
qualité que si vous allez dans des
produits de suite beaucoup plus haut de
gamme mais néanmoins ça peut être
franchement pas mal ça peut vous
permettre d'aller dans des technologies
auxquelles vous ne pourriez pas avoir
accès si non parce que forcément ça
coûte tout de suite rapidement chez en
tout cas donc voilà donc c'est pas mal
d'un produit que j'ai récupéré depuis
quelques temps je vais vous les montrer
je vous présente les produits un parent
vous allez voir ya toi qui sont
franchement cool on va changer un peu
l'éclairage ouais ça va être un truc un
peu plus au rembourrés 1 voilà aurores
boréales j'adore c'est beaucoup mieux
alors je vous montre un peu aujourd'hui
les produits que j'ai ici j'ai
sélectionné une enceinte de la marque
dos une deuxième enceinte de la marque
power à de plus petits formats
j'ai un petit casque un casque de la
marque mezze mèze mezze sait pas trop
comment ça se prononce cinq est un
roumain j'aime beaucoup avec du bois
vous allez voir ce côté c'est hyper
hyper joly j'ai récupéré un deuxième
casque à casque de gaming de la marque
quelle dose de cool j'ai récupéré de
chez sans marque ça ça vient tout droit
de californie un objectif pour améliorer
les photos sur votre smartphone ça c'est
un zoom téléobjectif pour iphone 10 mais
vous allez voir
pour d'autres smartphones aussi ça
s'écoule toujours chez sans marque un
filtre neutre
vous allez voir pour bien exposer vos
images assez cool j récupérer une montre
connectés qui n'ont de connectés qui est
pas cher qui est sympa et j'ai récupéré
un short gris un shooter grimm
c'est un grip de de jesse nos bagues ça
c'est cool voilà donc quelques petits
objets vous allez voir ils sont cools et
que vous direz vous un commentaire
ce que vous en pensez le cas groupés
plus tout si tout ça comment voilà
c'est tout petit tout petit tout petit
monde connecté starter et guides en fait
vouloir charger directement usb charge
vous la charger directement dans votre
ordinateur est comme ça dont vous pouvez
l'utiliser on voit la charge de regarder
ensemble
[Musique]
là elle se charge ou à décharge et on
verra après ensuite on a des produits de
100 marques ça c'est pour faire vos
photos sur votre smartphone avec ce
produit vous avez deux possibilités la
toute première si vous avez un iphone 10
vous le prenez vous mettez ça hancock
d'ailleurs votre smartphone et vous
allez venir fixer l'appareil photo le
téléobjectif juste derrière donc ça a
bien évidemment hop vous aller
l'installer dessus où vous avez votre
smartphone vous mettez votre coque
derrière ça marche fait des belles
photos si vous n'avez pas d'iphone dit
ce qui est souvent le cas de pas mal de
monde
vous pouvez l'utiliser avec n'importe
quel smartphone vous avez une pince très
pratique la pince vous l'installer
directement sur votre pinceau
vous prenez votre smartphone et vous
venez passez directement dessus alors
attention ça dépend des smartphones
parce que là typiquement sont moins de
plus saab le même van écran mais après
tout pourquoi pas là c'est avec hop je
l'enlève c'est sans revenir zoom est
donc là pour le coup je suis zoomer
dézoomer et si je l'enlève up et si
jésus complètement
voilà donc ça c'est cool en gros ça va
permettre à votre appareil photo de
votre smartphone d'avoir un zoom qui va
encore plus loin directement grâce à de
l'optique si vous avez un smartphone qui
n'a pas de zoom optique mais qui
accueille zoom numérique vous allez
pouvoir récupérer un zoom optique
vraiment sa vie pour les fans du congo
au lieu d'avoir une fois de vous allez
pouvoir aller encore plus loin et
franchement ça c'est cool dont vous avez
ça c'est sans marque
on a aussi autre chose qu'on a les
filtres son match
l'assemblage 5 si je le mets devant ça
va complètement filtré déjà par rapport
à ce que je vais avoir donc ça va être
vraiment bien ces gens le le plaquer
c'est pas fait pour ce n'est pas du tout
fait pour qui celui là
donc là lorsque vous avez beaucoup
lumière en extérieur c'est bien voyez ça
change complètement déjà l'exposition
c'est vraiment pas mal et j'ai le
troisième qui est là c'est assez ouf
et ça je voulais le fixe est ici
directement ce qui fait que vos photos
non plus tout sans même la même chose on
vous en avait trois différents c'est
vachement bien et ça va complètement
vous permettra d'optimiser vos photos
sur votre iphone sur tous vos
smartphones et ça franchement croyez moi
c'est franchement hyper hyper hyper cool
casque de gaming dodo cool c'est c'est
énorme
j'ai jamais compris pourquoi les casque
gaming il était aussi énorme moi j'ai
une petite tête c'est pas trop mal le
confort seul reproche que je pourrais
lui faire projet pas une recette
tu peux passer mon doigt un peu le
rythme là j'ai un peu d espaces et ils
se connectent bien évidemment en usb la
qualité pas complètement mal mais c'est
très flatteur au niveau des basses et
des grâces
pour la gemmi rammstein c'est sa tartine
un peu franchement la qualité audio lu
pas mal hein ça manque un peu de
brillance un peu de précision sur les
aigus mais il ya des graves
il ya de la basse c'est pas mal c'est
vraiment pas mal fichu autres produits
qu'on a on audio qui est plutôt juste
cool c'est le casque de maison mais je
n'arrive jamais avec leur nom je sais
pas je vous dirais un site quel nom
jeudi mais ce n'est aux jo c'est un
casque qui nous vient tout droit de
roumanie et je trouve qu'ils ont un
produit qui fait vachement premium c'est
vraiment très jolie là le côté bois là
le choix des matériaux vraiment bien
réussi j'adore ce côté bois avec le
petit logo derrière je trouve qu'ils ont
vraiment fait un super super super
boulot reste plus qu'à voir maintenant
au niveau de l'audio si ça tient sa
promesse médiums sont très bien c'est
beaucoup plus brillant que leur casque
il ya du grave ça manque un peu de
basses mal côté c'est normal on est
quand même quelque chose de beaucoup
plus petit mais la qualité est
franchement bien vous avez un micro
dessus là dont vous pouvez passer des
coups de fil directement là vous avez
une petite télécommande pour allumer
pour éteindre le petit os 9 les tuons
plus c'est vachement cool vous avez
différentes tailles pour le casque c'est
non franchement vous pouvez l'emmener
partout et vous vous avez le petit filet
là ça pour moi c'est vraiment moi ou
vous avez tous est dans un excellent
rapport qualité prix excellent produit
ensuite on va se retrouver avec des
agents 5
on va commencer avec une petite enceinte
connecter le tous ça c'est du petit
format bluetooth mais bombe petites
enceintes price et l'a dit jamie lee
c'est une
on a un petit oiseau s'enlacent à vivre
5 watts
elle se recharge en deux à trois heures
que vous allez l'éditeur des coûts toi
je te voyais mettez à 50%
c'est pas mal c'est tout petit ça
redescend rouge manchon ça court ça ça
coûte vraiment pas cher vous le posez
souvient pour tous vous l'emmenez à la
plage avec des amis pour boire un verre
ce que vous voulez ça c'est vraiment top
pour l'heure toutes les connectiques à
l'intérieur on à jack vers jack je pense
pour brancher directement sur la page du
bluetooth on a le câble usb pour
recharger et on a la petite est depuis
pour l'emmener avec soin et là c'est
nickel on continue dans les ans un peu
plus gros mark just one of extra basse
vous avez le pas à lever de commande
toute la connectique derrière là dessus
il ya vachement plus de grave et la
verna bouton ex travail
ça développe vachement de basse
[Musique]
oh
vous avez une batterie de 2200 millions
père vous avez deux haut parleurs de 10
watts à l'intérieur vous le recharger en
micronésie meurtre attaques est super
cool et pareil l'intérieur vous avez des
connectiques vous avez câble mini jack
mini jack pour brancher directement si
vous avez une source au nepad bluetooth
et vous rechargez en micro usb
maintenant il nous reste le shooteur
grippe alors vous allez voir ce temps
gris ça c'est un truc cool qui vous
permet de déclencher des photos à
distance truc là c'est vraiment génial
je vous explique à quoi ça sert en fait
vous imaginez vous voulez faire des
photos vous dites bon mon smartphone
gens et de faire des photos j'ai pas
envie de m'amuser avec le bouton sur le
dessus pour faire des photos
alors vous pouvez l'utiliser comme ça
vous le prenez vous le posez comme ça
vous allumez votre appareil photo
là typiquement hop je suis en mode photo
j'appuie sans boutons ça me fait une
photo donc là on dirais ok c'est bien
mignon je peux appuyer là je peux le
faire
j'ai aussi mes boutons qui savent faire
des photos c'est pas faux mais là où ça
va plus loin où la hausse est vraiment
intéressant vous pouvez les fixer sur un
petit pied dont vous le posez sur un
trépied vous posez votre smartphone et
là vous enlevez cette petite partie là
ce qui fait que vous pouvez partir à
distance qui m'éloigne j'ai ma commande
japy dessus et ça me fait des photos
donc ce qui fait que mon appareil photo
je peux le poser quelque part ça ne sert
de télécommande bluetooth pour
télécommander mon appareil photo
donc là je le fais en mode photo mais je
peux le faire également en mode vidéo
tac j'appuie ça me lance ma vidéo ça
commence à filmer et là mon petit
appareil il est vraiment pratique
j'aurais pu s'arrête et ça pour
enregistrer des séquences à distance par
exemple si vous faites du blog si vous
voulez film et vous posez votre appareil
et vous avez marre d'avoir du goût de
rush de vous en train de vous déplacer
vous le posez pas vous appuyer
vous dites ce que vous aviez vous fait
tant que pour appuyer et pour faire des
photos de vous à distance par exemple
parce que on le voit typiquement avec la
samsung galaxy note 9
le style et c'est râlant télécommande
pour faire des photos mais la grâce à
cet accessoire vous pouvez le faire
et franchement si couleur vous avez la
fonction que pour le mettre sur un pied
pas sur un pied vous avez une petite
pile avec vous avez une petite lanières
pour venir attaché up directement autour
de votre poignet pour palper enfin le
truc est franchement hyper hyper hyper
cool c'est just mobile qui fait ça et
c'est vraiment une super solution retour
à votre monde connecté donc la gelée
mise avec mon application est en train
de la paramétrer
vous mettez votre taille votre sexe
votre âge tout ça tout ça vous mettez
votre objectif de pas votre objectif de
sommeil votre objectif de poids vous
mettez tout ça vous leur entrée et
ensuite votre monde est directement
connecté en bluetooth forcément vous
avez ici tous vos détails dans votre
application votre appareil l'utilisateur
enfin toutes vos infos sur votre sommeil
vous avez tous directement à l'intérieur
ici dans votre app
ça c'est cool bon la montre après quant
à elle n est pas complètement dingue
l'écran ici n'est pas tactile vous avez
juste un petit bouton qui en dessous qui
va vous donner votre nombre de pas votre
fréquence cardiaque
vous allez avoir ensuite cela la
distance que vous avez marché faire la
course en vélo et c'est à peu près tout
ça vous donne la météo directement en
liaison avec votre smartphone votre
batterie si vous avez de nous tous à
vous donnent leur voix là mais tout ce
pilote là dessus directement sur votre
application
voilà pour ces quelques produits tech à
moins de 100 euros je vous donne les
prix le téléobjectif 200 marques coûte
99 99 dollars à peu près et 87 euros et
franchement la qualité est super bien
vous avez ensuite les filtres qui vont
coûter à peu près 70 dollars soit 61
euros la montre connectés coûte un petit
peu moins de 40 euros écoute 39,99 euros
le casque audio mèze mezze classique
coûte quant à lui 79 euros ta grosses
enceintes dose coûte 49,99 euros
le chemin grippe a pour faire vos photos
à distance coûte 45,90 la petite
enceinte power had coûte 21 euros 99 et
enfin vous avez le casque des gaming et
de cool qui coûtent entre 15 à 20 euros
sur amazon tous ces produits je vous
hais les liens dans la description vous
pouvez aller les voir s'il vous
intéresse aujourd'hui formant un peu à
part vous me direz en commentaire ce que
vous en pensez
est ce que ça vous intéresse des vidéos
où je vous présente des produits à moins
de 100 euros
des produits tech ça peut être pour
l'audio ça peut être pour de la vidéo
pourquoi pas même des smartphones il en
existe des tablettes va vous ne verrez
tout ça
si les produits à moins de 100 euros 150
euros voire 200 euros ça vous botte
comme ça peut-être qu'on reconduire à
l'expérience dépend de vous ce que vous
allez me dire un bon commentaire en
attendant vous invite à très bien vous
portez à l'est
gardez les différentes playlists et
d'autres vidéos parce que il ya aussi
plein de produits cool même s'ils sont
forcément un peu plus cher qui portez
vous bien soyez sages et puis à très
bientôt
ciao